PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Are you playing around
with a powerful complex
image classification model
and training it in Colab
or Kaggle Notebooks?
Well, it takes too long to
train with the free GPUs.
Stay tuned to learn
how you can instantly
scale to train with more data,
more GPUs, and a larger scale.
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
I am Priyanka Vergadia.
And today we're talking about
scaling machine learning
training resources right
from within Colab and Kaggle
Notebooks using
tensorflow_cloud.
Let's say you're playing around
with a powerful complex image
classification model
such as NASNet,
and training it in Colab.
It takes a couple of hours
to train with a free GPU
that Colab gives you.
Also, it may not even be
feasible to train on large data
sets because the training
could go over the free 12 hours
window.
Wouldn't it be nice
if I could instantly
scale to training on more
data and with more GPUs?
And once you have
the model trained,
you often need to run multiple
experiments to fine tune
and optimize the
hyperparameters to continue
to improve your model.
Hundreds of runs
are needed sometimes
to find a setting that
results in the best accuracy.
If you participate in a
competition on Kaggle,
you know that often, very small
accuracy differences separate
winners in the leaderboard.
This kind of experimentation
takes a very long time
and a lot of resources.
Wouldn't it be nice
if you could run
all these experiments
concurrently using
more resources?
Well, that's where
tensorflow_cloud comes in.
It's a client-side library for
training your TensorFlow model
on Vertex AI.
It provides APIs for a seamless
transition from local debugging
to distributed training
and hyperparameter
tuning within Google Cloud.
You can directly
use it from a Colab
Notebook, or a Kaggle kernel.
It handles Cloud-specific
tasks such as creating
virtual machine instances
and distribution strategies
for your model automatically.
For distributed tuning jobs,
tensorflow_cloud sets up
model callbacks to
capture model checkpoints,
and TensorBoard
logs automatically.
Now, I'm sure you're
excited to see how it works.
So let's take a peek into it.
First, we will run the
initial one-time setup
to make sure the Google Cloud
assets are all configured.
Link to this Colab is included
in the description below.
For that, we set up the project
in the Google Cloud console
at cloud.google.com, and
grab the project name
and the project number.
In the Colab or Kaggle notebook
you're using, plug those in.
Link to this notebook is
included in the description
below.
Then make a choice,
depending on where
you're running the notebook.
I'm using Colab here, so I will
set up auth for Colab Notebook
here.
But if you're using Kaggle,
then do the same for Kaggle.
You need a billing account
attached to your Google Cloud
project.
So the next step is to
link your billing account.
When you entered your
credit card information
during Google Cloud sign-up,
it created a default billing
account for you.
That's the one we are
going to use here.
Next, enable the required Cloud
APIs, including the Vertex AI
APIs, which will allow us
to kick off the training
jobs within Google Cloud,
and the Cloud Build
API to build our Docker images.
We create a storage
bucket in this step
to store our temporary
assets and to save the model
checkpoints.
Now, if you're going to also
perform hyperparameter tuning,
then we need a
service account, which
is a special kind
of account used
by the tensorflow_cloud tuner
to create the hyperparameter
tuning jobs in Vertex AI.
In this step, we are
creating that service account
and providing it the right
access to create the job.
At this point, we have our
set-up complete with a project
in Google Cloud, a service
account that will create jobs
in Vertex AI, and the
Cloud storage bucket that
will store our model assets.
We can reduce the setup
with various notebooks.
In each notebook, you will
need to repeat the Step
2 to add the Google Cloud auth
credentials to your notebook.
This will allow your notebook
to connect to the project.
Now that the setup
is out of the way,
let's run some
distributed training
and see how tensorflow_cloud
helps scale the distributed
training resources
in Google Cloud.
This example is based on
the image classification
we are fine-tuning
with EfficientNet
to train a NASNet mobile model.
First step, import
all the requirements.
Then, set the project
parameters that we
got from our setup notebook.
And authenticate the notebook
to our Google Cloud project.
Then we load and
prepare the data,
split it into training
and test data sets,
add a preprocessing layers
API for image augmentation,
image resizing, rotation,
flip and contrast.
Next we load the model
and prepare for training.
Here, we load a NASNet mobile
pre-trained model with weights
and unfreeze a few layers
for fine-tuning the model
to better match the data set.
Then train the model
using model.fit.
But notice the remote function.
It determines whether your
code is being executed
locally or in the Cloud.
And allows for the separate
destination of fit parameters
for local and remote execution.
Now we're ready to train the
model remotely on Google Cloud
platform.
We submit a training
job using this step
where we define the parameters
within the run function.
Our distribution
strategy, requirements
for any custom models,
Docker configuration,
and master and worker
machine configurations.
Once done, we can monitor
our job in TensorBoard.
This may take a few
minutes, since the logs
start to populate once
the training begins.
Now that we know how to kick
off a training job using
tensorflow_cloud, execute a
distributed hyperparameter
tuning job yourself.
It's fairly similar.
You'll be using the
CloudTuner function, which
defines tuning parameters for
your hyperparameter tuning jobs
that are executed concurrently
on Google Cloud platform.
You also get to define
the distribution strategy,
the custom modules
in requirements.text,
the Docker image, and the
number of concurrent tuning jobs
that you want to run.
If you run into any question,
watch my walkthrough
in the video linked below.
All right.
In this episode, we talked
about scaling machine
learning training resources
using tensorflow_cloud.
Give it a try yourself
using the links below
and let me know how it
goes in the comments.
If you like this video, give
us a like and subscribe.
If you have any questions,
reach me on Twitter @pvergadia.